jusqu'où les prix du carburant
grimperont t-il la facture pour les
automobilistes ne cesse de gonfler des
records sont battus tous les jours
depuis le début de l'année la hausse
atteint 26% sur un an pour le gasoil et
21% pour le sans plomb 95 les prix ont
largement dépassé ceux de fin 2018 début
du mouvement des gilet jaune et dans les
yvelines la hausse des prix se fait
également ressentir
lorsqu'on qu'on fasse des plans à
aiguiller comme ça bah on n'a rien que
pour 60 et j'ai même pas le plein donc
ça fait bah ça fait pas du bien avant
j'étais
10 10 centimes moins cher même la
discount elle est beaucoup plus chère
maintenant et moi fort de faire des
allers-retours oui c'est à dire une
bêtise 50 balles de plus par par mois
environ voire plus tout dépend de
comment je roule mais en général ces
serveurs je préférerais le maître avait
un peu dans l'essence dans les loisirs
mais
enfin même pour faire des courses à la
limite je préfère consommer pour manger
que consommer pour rouler c'est toujours
un peu saint cast est maintenant de
rouler en voiture ça devient difficile
alors où trouver l'essence la moins
chère dans les yvelines grâce au site
mon carbure points comme nous avons
réalisé un comparatif dans le nord des
yvelines le total access relais de la
couture h au four les bonnes hier est
l'une des stations services les moins
chers du côté de saint quentin en
yvelines et de versailles grand parc ce
sont les stations bp attrape auchan à
plaisir ou encore leclerc à bois d'arcy
qui seront à privilégier et dans le sud
des yvelines le supermarché auchan de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines affichent des
prix bas ce contexte profite au
bioéthanol ce carburant vert est
composée jusqu'à 85 % d'éthanol à partir
de blé de maïs ou encore de betteraves
sa consommation a augmenté de 33 %
l'année dernière la hausse des prix des
carburants a rendu le superéthanol
encore plus attractif sur la fin de
l'année depuis le mois d'octobre et la
début janvier on constate également que
l'écart de prix reste très important
entre le superéthanol et les essence
sans plomb 95 e10 le superéthanol est
vendu plus de la moitié moins cher que
les essence classique pour faire face à
l'augmentation des prix des carburants
le premier ministre jean castex a
annoncé une réelle de 10 % du barème
kilométrique
pour en bénéficier il faut indiquer dans
sa déclaration d'impôt sur le revenu les
kilomètres parcourus pour se rendre sur
son lieu de travail